You have joined the RN
in this battle of the European elections.
You will be
No.
3 on the list led by Jordan Bardella.
Why is that?
Because for several years,
I have been to the heart
of the institutions of the European Union
and I was able to measure the urgency to act
against illegal immigration.
The emergency
because the European Commission,
in reality
sees illegal immigration
as 1 project and not as 1 problem.
However,
the National Rally
and the party that has the lucidity to make the real observation,
who has the courage,
the willingness to implement the proposals.
And it is the party in France,
the Rassemblement National,
who will have the ability to.